autre consultation on reste en alsace où
les habitants sont une nouvelle fois
appelé à se prononcer sur une éventuelle
possible future fusion entre le
haut-rhin et le bas-rhin des alsaciens
toujours aussi hostile en même temps à
la nouvelle grande région grand est à
strasbourg et obernai puis mangé
l'aileron slope hier officiellement la
région alsace n'existe plus mais le
symbole est resté et l'attachement à
l'ancien nom est toujours aussi fort
pour une majorité d'alsaciens
l'intégration au sein de la nouvelle
région grand-est n'a jamais été comprise
et encore moins acceptés pour s'en
convaincre il suffit de tendre le micro
la réponse est invariable on est trop
loin et trop éloignée ces six trop grand
levante est on atteint une telle
particularité on va lire au niveau
touristique la gastronomie le vignoble
j'ai l'impression que c'est ce grand
test nous fait perdre notre identité des
arguments pour la sortie de la région
grand est mise en avant par les deux
départements alsaciens ils ont lancé une
vaste consultation citoyenne objectif la
création d'une nouvelle collectivité
territoriale unique son nom ce sera
l'alsace forcément c'est ce qui nous
fédère et qui nous réunit mais en plus
ce qui est important pour nous c'est que
les de réelles compétences des
compétences que l'état pourrait nous
transférer sur les routes nationales
qu'on pourrait gérer en proximité sur le
transfrontalier mobiliser rassembler les
propositions pour quitter la région
grand-est histoire culture économique
pour les alsaciens les différences sont
trop nombreux on a une économie plus
forte sur ici or là je travaille en a
toujours et puis surtout à sa frontière
on a toujours du travail
si on n'est qu'une seule alsace avec un
seul département pourquoi pas passer sa
vie de multiples et les fonctionnaires
c'est pas forcément une mauvaise chose m
la consultation va durer trois mois
difficiles à un rapport sera rendu au
premier ministre emmanuel macron devrait
également se prononcer lors de sa visite
officielle dans la région